let's say we have the function f of x
is equal to x to the sixth minus three x
to the fifth
and my question to you
is using only what we know about
derivatives try to figure out over what
interval or intervals is this function
decreasing pause the video and try to
figure that out
all right now let's do this together
so we know that a function is decreasing
when its derivative is negative or
another way to say it it's going to be
decreasing when f prime of x
is
less than zero
so what is f prime of x well we could
use the derivative rules and derivative
properties we know we apply the power
rule to x to the sixth we bring the six
out front or multiply the one
coefficient here times six to get
six
x
to the fifth decrement that exponent
minus
bring the 5 times the 3 minus 15
x to the we decrement the 5 so x to the
fourth and we need to figure out over
what intervals is this going to be less
than 0
and now let's see how we can simplify
this a little bit both of these terms
are divisible by x to the fourth and
they're both divisible by three so let's
factor out a three
x to the fourth
times if you factor out a three x to the
fourth here you're left with a
2
x and then over here you have minus 5
has to be
less than zero any interval where this
is true we are going to be decreasing
now how do we get this to be less than
zero well if i take the product of two
things and it's less than zero that
means that they have to have different
signs either one's positive and the
other is negative or one's negative and
the other is positive so we have two
situations so we could say either
either
three x to the fourth is greater than
zero and
and
two x minus five is less than zero so
that's one situation i'll do this in a
different color
or
and i'll do this one in a different
color
three x to the fourth is less than zero
and
two x
minus five is greater than 0.
actually let me stay on the second case
first are there any situations where 3x
to the 4th can be less than 0
you take any number you take it to the
4th power even if it's a negative it's
going to become a positive so you can't
get a negative expression right over
here
so actually the second condition is
impossible to obtain you can't get any
situation for any x where 3x to the
fourth is less than zero so we can rule
this one out and so this is our best
hope so under what conditions is three x
to the fourth greater than zero
well if you divide both sides by three
you get x to the fourth is
greater than zero
and if you think about it this is gonna
be true for any x value that is not
equal to zero even if you have a
negative value there if you have a
negative one you take it to the fourth
power becomes a positive one only zero
will be equal to zero when you take it
to the fourth power so one way you could
say this is going to be true for any
non-zero x or we could just say x does
not equal 0. and
this is a little bit more
straightforward we add 5 to both sides
we get 2x is less than 5. divide both
sides by 2 you get x is less than 5
halves
so it might be tempting to say all right
the intervals that matter are all the
x's less than 5 halves but x cannot be
equal to 0.
now is that the entire interval where
our function is decreasing
well let's think about what happens at 0
itself we are decreasing over the
interval from negative infinity all the
way up to 0 and we're also decreasing
from zero to five halves and so if we're
decreasing right to the left of zero and
we're decreasing right to the right of
zero we're actually going to be
decreasing at zero at we're also going
to be decreasing at zero as well so
there's something interesting here even
though the derivative at x equals zero
is going to be equal to zero we are
still decreasing there
and so the interval that we care about
the interval over which we're decreasing
is just x is less than five halves
and we can see that by graphing the
function i graphed it on desmos and you
can see here that the function is
decreasing from negative infinity it's
decreasing at a slower and slower rate
we get to zero still decreasing to the
left of zero and then it continues to
decrease to the right of zero so any any
value any x value to the left of zero
it's going the value of the function is
going to be larger than f of zero and x
to the right of 0 the value of the
function is going to be less than the
function at 0. so it's actually
decreasing through 0 even though the
slope of the tangent line at 0 is 0 even
though it's not negative and then we
keep decreasing so we're decreasing for
all values of x
less than
5 halves which you can see visually here